the equalizer - is directed by Antoine
Fuqua once again and sees Denzel
Washington reprising his role as Robert
McCall the ultimate badass who will take
you down in a second but he's more of
the protector of the people now he sort
of left those old days behind and he
looks for people who he feels are
wronged and tries to write it
he's a lyft driver and sometimes his
passengers are saying things that he
doesn't like and he follows them and
make sure that things work out the way
he thinks they should but when someone
that he cares for gets in harm's way he
finds himself back in the fray again I
enjoyed the first film I thought it was
alright I haven't seen it since theaters
I didn't really feel like watching it
again but as a one-time watch I thought
it was pretty fun and Denzel Washington
I mean I can watch him do just about
anything to be honest the man's a legend
and he proves that again in this film
because he's easily the best part of it
there are scenes with him that might
feel more familiar with any other actor
but he just takes them to another level
and I've been a fan of Antoine Fuqua for
a long time I think he's a fairly
overlooked director actually I think he
makes a lot of really good movies that
sometimes critics don't really
appreciate that much his films are
rarely pretentious they're usually just
really well-made gritty dramas and
sometimes action films like training day
the Magnificent Seven
with equalizer - I think it's about the
same as the first I thought it was
alright I enjoyed it it has some really
good sequences denzel's amazing there's
a few scenes in particular that are
actually quite great one scene that's
with Denzel and a young kid in the film
named miles portrayed by Ashton Sanders
from moonlight who was terrific in this
film there's a great scene between them
after this confrontation that occurs in
this house where Denzel has kind of
become a father figure to this young
person who's an artist but he has a hard
time dealing with where he's from
because where he's from it's not normal
to want to be an artist it's you you
make money doing other things and Denzel
is there like saying like no you don't
have to do that and we've seen this in
movies before it's very similar to other
friendships we've seen built in films
where an older person is trying to keep
a young person away from drugs or a life
in crime or something like that but
there's just a powerful scene in this
film that's basically like a mini-lesson
and acting from Denzel and
it's kind of worth the price of the
ticket admission alone just for that
scene the action sequences are also very
exciting extremely brutal very bloody
Denzel does some things in between the
punches that I will remember forever
just little moments that with this that
these guys in a hotel I don't even want
to ruin it for you it's such a little
moment I kind of want to talk about it
but I'm not going to it's such a small
thing he does in between the action that
I just I love I wish the plotting though
was as strong as the action and as
strong as the acting because it takes a
long time for things to feel cohesive we
have this series of events that occurs
in Brussels and it takes forever to
really feel like it has anything to do
with the rest of the film it's basically
a lot of sequences where we see Denzel
go up against people who are assholes
and he beats the shit out of them which
can be really entertaining but it just
takes a long time to feel like the film
is progressing somewhere and I think it
makes a bit of a mistake when it tries
to add other families and other people
that Denzel is helping and actually
makes it an important through-line to
the story there's an older person who's
looking for a painting and it had some
again really good acting this actor who
portrays his older man his name is Orson
Bean he was incredible but that whole
storyline just sort of sunk underneath
the rest of the film and I love this set
up for the big finale but the last
confrontation I thought was kind of weak
it felt very stunt-double heavy which
was a bit of a disappointment overall I
think this movie is about as enjoyable
as the first for myself one thing that I
think is definitely stronger here is
both films have a relationship between
Robert McCall and a younger person he's
trying to help in the first film it was
a character named Terry played by Chloe
grace Moretz and here it's miles by
Ashton Sanders and I loved that
storyline in this film and I thought it
was much stronger than the Chloe grace
Moretz won in the first and so that
specific aspect of equaliser 2 is better
and there are some really good sequences
with some terrific dialogue it's really
the plotting that's the biggest issue
here it takes a long time for the film
to feel like it's going somewhere but
with denzel's magnetic acting the
brutally violent action sequences and
Antoine Fuqua is gritty direction
there's a lot to like here but I don't
think it's gonna be particularly
memorable for most action fans although
I could recommend a one time watch for
sure I'm gonna give equalizer to a B -
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]